[Music]
all right so
moyes is here and so i guess what people
don't know so you started um you started
a couple businesses people mostly know
you from native so you created native
which has the popular deodorant brand
you sold it to procter gamble for
reported hundred million dollars which i
think is uh
one of the better ddc exits because you
only raised like four million dollars i
want to say less than that even we
raised 500 000 actually
oh my god okay so you raised 500 000 and
by the way i don't know if you know this
i remember i was in a mastermind group
with your brother
and i was like and he was like in
between he already sold his company so
he's kind of floating in between things
it's like why do you show up to the
mastermind if you don't really have a
business that you're working on so i
think he was kind of like fishing and he
was like you know my brother's got this
interesting business and i was like i
was like okay
you know i didn't even know i didn't
know him very well time i was like
didn't you know you had her bra he's
like and i was ready for this like big
tech idea
and he's like yeah he's like selling
like this uh natural deodorant like and
he made it sound like you're like
sitting at home packing the deodorant
like containers by hand and he's like
he kind of was under playing he's like
it's really cool you know it's paraben
free i didn't know what a paraben was
and he's like it's aluminum free or
whatever
and he's like yeah it's doing pretty
well and then he started to say the
numbers and i was like whoa
um that's actually like really good i
was like so how much has he raised he's
like i don't know if he's like he's
raised like nothing and so that's when
you got on my radar and you i feel like
you operated very quietly you're kind of
like me where when you're doing
something that's working you shut the
hell up and when
you're not when you're just thinking
about ideas you're like super loud to
bounce them around off people is that
your strategy that's exactly right in
fact uh we've done no pr for native
until uh after we sold the business i
remember we had all these news
publications reaching out to us and i
took one interview with i think it was
like retail dive or somebody and they
were like we want to talk about this
deodorant company because we haven't
heard of that and you know they're like
who are you guys what are you doing um
and we sort of uh talked about the
business and they wrote an article and
after that i was like i'm never talking
about the business again uh when we went
to go fundraise like we talked to a few
people we talked to um
simon equity partners which is basically
uh the family office of like you know
the simon property group which owns a
bunch of malls across the united states
and uh we opened up our books them and
we're like here's our business and
they're like our job is to find
businesses like you and you know you're
down the street from us you're based in
san francisco your headquarters is three
blocks away from ours we've never heard
of this business and we should have
heard of it by now how come and we're
like you know we're not talking about
our business like no one walked around
with native t-shirts until after we made
it until after we'd made an exit and
then i was like okay now the brand can
exist and b we can be loud and public
about it
is that what is that is that paranoia is
it just focus is it strategy what why
why do it that way yeah yeah i think
it's two things um i think one is uh
fear which is like um fear of
embarrassment okay my business failed
and i was super public about it and now
it crashed and everybody's going to
think of me as a failure so i was like
we're not going to fail publicly if we
fail it'll be really quietly um and then
two was like
we failed the indian way and personal
shame
yeah that's right uh that's right no one
will be able to google me and be like
okay boys always a failure um and then
the other one was things were working so
well we're like okay we don't know how
this is working so well or why this is
working so well but we better not go
around thumping our chests saying this
is working really well because one i
believe it'll jinx us and i believe in
jinx and two other people just start
copying us and doing exactly what we're
doing and like you know i sold our isil
native in november 2017 we had a
competitor sell their business in
december 2017 a month a month after us
and you know the in 2018 2019
60 competitors in the natural deodorant
space popped up uh and every brand that
didn't have a natural deodorant was like
we should create a natural deodorant um
and then 60 brands were like hey we want
to create natural deodorant as our
flagship or our hero product and so by
like not thumping our chest and not
talking about our business we were able
to keep the category a little bit
quieter before we came out and said hey
this is a massive category and it's
really working
right and i i i
appreciate that about you guys i've
actually learned a little bit in that
regard in that i don't talk about my
ecommerce business
um or i'll reference it but i'll never
say the name or the brand or whatever
yeah
someone said yeah i also have a business
partner
yeah i have a business partner and they
don't want me to talk about it so i'm
also like okay cool yeah you know i'll
honor that wish but i i kind of came up
with this term because you and your
brother are the same in that
normally you guys are all the info flows
one way and this podcast is like the
rare exception where i get to ask you
questions
normally whenever i've seen your brother
or you in any social setting it's a
technique i call ollie boarding and it's
like waterboarding
but just with questions where you just
dump someone's head into a vat of your
non-stop flow of questions
and by the end they're like wait so
what's your name and what do you do and
you're like by then you're like i have
your p l
and like i have your whole family's
backstory and it's not like in an evil
way it's like genuine curiosity i think
is what i've come to see but it's also
very effective
um a is that true do you do believe that
am i am i characterizing it right and
then b is that like conscious or un did
you ever like
develop that as a skill or was that a
choice you made or just natural yeah i
think um a is it's partially right it's
more true with salomon with my brother
than it is with me and he does that to
me as well where like i'll tell him
about you know a meeting i had or a deal
that i'm looking at and you'll be he'll
ask me ridiculous questions he'll be
like what uh what did the lunch what did
the founder have for lunch on saturday
three months ago and i'm like i didn't
get into that level of detail you got to
stop asking those types of questions
uh but i do think we have genuine
curiosity of like what are what's making
other businesses work and what isn't i
remember we went to the super bowl um
you know four years ago or something
like that in atlanta and we were at the
super bowl party like the night before
the game and there were these two old
daisy uncles that were there as well and
uh they were there because they had they
owned marriott hotels and marriott had
invited them to the game in like their
private suite and you know they were
probably in their 50s and we asked them
so many ques i was like you know how
much do you have to pay marriott and
they also own like hilton hotels i was
like how much you have to pay hilton per
year marriott per year do you have debt
on the building you do what's your debt
like you know how often do you have to
renovate how much those renovations cost
uh how much like you know what does your
average occupancy look like and they
answered all these questions
and they were like it didn't seem
excited to answer them but they didn't
seem cautious like they didn't seem like
they were hesitant either and at the end
of all of these questions where we
literally did have their p l you know
we're like okay well you know they
didn't ask a single question they were
just like okay well uh great meeting you
guys and we're like all right i now
understand the hotel business from two
operators that have eight businesses
around the dallas fort worth area and
they didn't want to know anything about
us like why were we at the super bowl
party how did we get here how did we
make our money they didn't ask a single
question so i think there is a genuine
curiosity that we have that sometimes is
lost on other people
that's that's exactly how it goes i've
seen it and then also you had like a
brunch
i saw you tweet out like oh inviting
some ddc friends over like who else have
a bunch of d2c people and i was like oh
what a nice guy just being social or
whatever i had a friend who went to your
brunch and he's like yeah the brunch is
basically boy sits at the head of the
table and he's like all right what's
your cak what's
you're like asking a bunch of questions
and i was like that sounds about right
and i learned this from your brother i
was like because i watched him one time
and i was like
first when i talk to your brother now
i'm like it's like a duel like he
doesn't know this but in my head i'm
like i'm gonna ask
whatever n number of questions you ask n
plus one will be asked back to you
um like you know because i will not be
out questioned because i know the
technique but i started i started
watching him when he talked to other
people and i was like how does he get
them to divulge so much information and
again not in a
bad way but just like what gets people
in the flow of talking i'm like okay so
first he's genuinely curious like he's
super engaged he's not looking around
he's not looking at his phone he's
actually looking them in the eye he's
asking a bunch of questions i've noticed
he does two things
when they're saying something he uh
likes or is like a smart thing he gives
them tons of like you know nodding yep
that makes total sense got it love it
and then when they say something really
stupid or weird or that something makes
no sense
i noticed that when somebody does that
to me i'm like but that makes i like
kind of start judging them a little bit
and they can tell that i'm judging them
and that makes them clam up whereas
he'll just go he'll just laugh and be
like
amazing and then he says the word
amazing and then moves on and amazing
really means like wow it's amazing
you're so stupid or it's amazing you
think that or it's amazing that you
don't even know that but like he never
makes them feel bad he'll just be like
like amazing and then he'll just go on
to the next question and i realized that
that is how he keeps the constant flow
going so i'm studying this ollie
boarding technique and i think i'm going
to be pretty good at i'm going to be
like you know a franchisee of your of
your question i love that yeah first we
have to charge you per question then uh
but really he's like um i think the
other thing that he does really good or
do really well is that he's like how do
you think about something he never asked
like you know uh what's your calf he'll
be like how do you think about growth
when it comes to social ads and like you
know can you spend more there and the
question is really open-ended but he's
like aiming for something he really
wants a response and people uh like you
know subconsciously get to it and i've
started asking how do you think about
that all the time now because it really
gets people to open up and tell me about
how they're how they view their business
and not just like a standard number um
and i really like that question and i've
also franchised that from him
when i started my business the e-comm
one he i told him about it and he had
like you know some good questions and
then like you know
the way y'all's brains work it's just
like you know non-stop so i think at
like two in the morning that same night
he just sent or like actually was like
five nights later it was like completely
unrelated it was like five days later
two in the morning i get this email it's
one line from him and he just says
he says like with our business i knew we
just it was this we just need to do this
one thing and it would work like he
explained like the competitive like the
positioning like what we were going to
do different that was going to cause it
to work it was going to be x but with
why difference
what's that going to be for your
business and it was like that sent me
into like a three week spiral of being
like oh my god i need to know this
answer that is the important question as
i'm starting this business i really do
need to have like a very strong point of
view
on what's going to be the one thing that
we're going to do that's going to make
this business work better than
all the others that are out there or
better than you know how can we compete
given that we're years late to the party
and whatever else but it was such an
important question and i was like man
um
and like i ended up bringing them on as
kind of like an advisor but i was like
man this is the value of an advisor it's
not the answer but the question the
question that's going to make you
like think about your business in a way
or like reveal a shortcoming in your own
thinking
that you then get to go fill in that gap
for yourself
yeah i think there's a lot of truth to
that the one thing i would say is that
like um you know i've started an
e-commerce business and if someone asked
me that about native uh when i launched
the business i'd say i've got no idea
we're aluminum-free there are a bunch of
aluminum pre-deodorants right now we're
selling online is that better is that
better than selling in store i've got no
clue and so i think those questions are
really helpful but i think the fear that
some of those questions can cause in
terms of people being like i need to
figure out this answer before i can do x
or y before i can launch my product
before i can start spending marketing
dollars like you can figure out that
answer
uh well after your business is launched
and i think for native that really
changed like you know we were an
aluminum-free deodorant selling it on
the internet and i was like that's going
to be our competitive advantage and then
it became a little bit of like sense uh
you know like fragrances we have a
strategy of launching new fragrances
frequently and those fragrances are
different and people are gonna pantry
load and buy a bunch of deodorants so
it's not just buying one until you run
out but i've got seven because this is
gonna be your fragrance rather than your
perfume perfume or cologne uh and then
it was like different marketing ideas
and bundling products and launching new
categories like there are very few
brands that can expand from deodorant to
body wash to uh toothpaste like you know
old spice could never make a toothpaste
we're like we're gonna create a brand
that can do all of those and it stands
for better for you ingredients rather
than one single thing and i think that
question the answer that question
evolved and changed and i think that
question is great and people should
think about that in the back of their
minds but it shouldn't prevent them from
actually taking the first step to
launching their business
totally totally agree also about the
like progressive like iteration of that
question of the answer but also
um i also learned what a good answer to
that is a good answer is not
we're doing this magical thing that
nobody's doing because
usually that just doesn't exist like
realistically like that's probably a
signal that it's a bad idea not that
it's a great idea
um
and also not that like we are going to
jump through these 14 really hard to
jump through hoops like i'm gonna crack
i'm gonna be viral all the time it's
like oh god like that seems like a bad
strategy to back instead it was like
actually there's a category that people
want
and what we're gonna do is like people
don't don't like this one thing about
the main competitor we're gonna do that
one thing like it's just common sense
but we're gonna do that one thing
differently and like i'm just gonna
obsess over facebook ads in a way that
they're not like or just in a way that
will work like facebook ads are just
working for businesses like these so i'm
gonna do facebook ads it's like almost
the stupider the answer the better but
like the clearer the answer the better
too like if do you even know what you're
betting on that's like what do you think
is gonna work here and like can you back
that up as to why you think that's going
to work but you don't want it to be a
genius magical like
magical silver bullet solution that like
nobody has ever thought of and nobody
has ever pulled off because that's
usually just a sign of like weakness
actually in the plan
especially if you talk about like
partnership to collaborations where
people are like i'm betting my future on
the ability to get other people to do x
y and z like that's never gonna work i
couldn't agree more it could be look
we're gonna create a digital first brand
that looks better uh we're gonna have a
better user interface and we're gonna
have more uh better colors and it's
gonna look better on your countertop
like native deodorant or your bathroom
you know shelf like like native
deodorant and that was it like that was
the that's that's an entire plan and
that's perfectly fine
okay so so the idea is uh
example of doing that so you know the
the so most people who listen to this
are probably not not not brown or desi
they don't know this brand but like if
you've ever been to like an indian
grocer which there's you know all around
the country there's a bunch of things
like you know you go by go by you know
they're sort of like the ethnic foods
there's this brand called haldiram which
is basically they make like
just like this like
super addictive salty little snack it's
like fried it's like our equivalent of
chips it's like fried salty kind of
spicy and you just buy this thing it's
like it's like a trail mix basically
that's that's salty
and um
and so it's been around forever they do
like 500 million a year in sales they're
like like a juggernaut of a consumer
package good brand they're like super
profitable don't do any like advertising
and like they're just like
they're massive and so like i think one
idea is like holy rom but with like
packaging that's just different like
different packaging slightly better for
you like maybe it's baked and not fried
and like that's the whole business plan
like i don't need to know more to start
than just that and i think that that's a
plan somebody could take today and go
start like okay so then what are you
gonna do for this like i don't know or
the same as everybody else like you can
do i don't know or the same as everybody
else for all other questions as long as
you just had that one thing which is
like these guys do like 500 million in
sales and they sell mostly through these
like any grocers i'm gonna do that but
with better packaging because their
packaging looks like my mom's packaging
i'm just gonna make it look like my
packaging like you know the stuff i'm
used to buying yeah and i can cater to
caucasians as a result of that like you
know yeah
packaging that the entire world is going
to understand it's not available only at
ethnic grocers there it is that's our
business model
in a better bag
or like two-thirds of indians have
diabetes and i'm just going to make mine
like better for people with diabetes and
i'm just like it's baked not fried and
like it's better for you because of that
yeah you know the guys who started
nature naturebox was this a company
based in san francisco that's uh like
sold you uh snacks like trail mix
basically and shipped it either to your
home or your office their original
business model was we're gonna go buy
this at whole foods put it in different
size packaging and just ship it to your
house like you know what's the
difference between this and whole foods
trail mix
literally not no packaging difference no
uh ingredient difference they literally
go and buy it and you know ship it to
your house and that was it and instacart
like started and they're like what are
we gonna do you have a grocery list you
just email it to us and we're gonna go
shopping for it like really simple ideas
that we're not like you know
groundbreaking by any stretch of
imagination that builds huge businesses
and you invested in manscaped pretty
early on i think right yeah yeah i
invested in landscape probably three or
four years ago now
and so um
you invest in manscaped and it's been
one of your i think you tweeted out one
of your best performing investments
um
what did they do like what's their
version of this like the stupid simple
plan that like just makes sense and it
doesn't have to be rocket science but
like
a simple plan executed well what was
their version of that
yeah i think uh two things i think one
was they're like look we've created a
product specifically for your balls even
though the razor that works on your face
works on your like you know if you've
got an electric trimmer for your face
works on your balls as well it's not
like it's different hair it's possibly
more coarse but like that trimmer is
gonna work there and so they're like
look we've created an electric trimmer
specifically for your balls and like you
know that might appeal to people who
don't have electric trimmers for their
face like i imagine you do it's hard to
keep these beards uh trimmed well but
like you know if you've got it for your
face you can probably use the same thing
for your balls if you're comfortable
with that they're like hey you're using
a gillette razor blade because you're
clean shaven we've got something
specific for your balls so i think that
was really smart though like hey use
this product for a category that you
probably aren't using it for
uh and then two was like branding and
name they're like you know they got the
name right they got the trademark right
i think those were probably really hard
for them to get although i'm not like
involved enough to know that um and like
you know they've done a good job with
like unique and differentiated branding
look they had um they had a barge sale
up and down um
uh south beach in miami and they had a
big billboard on it and it said god bush
uh use manscaped uh like they've done
really unique things in order to get
their name out there in a way that i
think a lot of other direct consumer
businesses have failed where we're like
you know native would run billboards and
we're like here's an aluminum free
deodorant please come buy it it really
didn't get your attention these guys
have done a good job of that um and like
you know today they posted on uh they
have a billboard in new york city right
now instead of the heart emoji it's an
upside down heart emoji so it looks like
a you know a testicle sac basically uh
that's really clever branding and like
really clever thinking and so they're
fantastic at that and i think what's
really difficult is that stuff doesn't
scale it's not like if the guy who's
like you know if there's two guys
thinking about this kind of stuff and
they retire you're not gonna be able to
hire or teach that skill to somebody
else you've got to find two rock stars
that are able to pull that off otherwise
and i think that's going to be difficult
for them but so far they're just
knocking it out of the park
and you see a ton of brands a ton of ddc
brands you're probably like you know one
of when somebody has a dvc company
you're probably one of the most i don't
know desired like investor advisor
type dudes like that's your authority
right people want to do what you've done
and then you've also invested in so many
that now you have
that portfolio and experience as well
but you also see a bunch of ddc brands
do stupid [__] so what are some of the
like kind of like give me your rant on
the things you see d2c brands doing
wrong what are some of the common
mistakes you see that drive you nuts
because i know that like both you and
your brother it's like operational like
um
you know
operational excellence is what turns you
on and operational like you know uh
ignorance or whatever you know
is what like you know drives you nuts
and so give me some of the things you
see dd brands doing wrong or stupidly
yeah over hiring and like um spending
money on dumb things like you know
uh native was doing uh probably we were
in a 50 million run rate or close to a
50 million dollar run rate um
when we sold the business uh and we had
eight people at the time and when i left
you know certainly doing north of 100
million a year and you know we probably
had 30 or 30 or so people on the team
like there were not that many people for
a brand that was doing a lot of revenue
you know i've walked into offices where
people have 20 people you know there'll
be 20 people doing 2 million or 4
million in revenue and i'm like what are
all of these human beings doing like if
they're got this many people here send
them to the subway and handing out free
like coupon cards to people who are
getting off the subway this is too many
people inside your office to be working
on a 4 million a year brand and so i
think that's a that's a real like you're
burning way too much money if you have
that many people
um you know goldman sachs had the
standard of like we want to do one
million in revenue per employee that we
have that should be something that's
rather easy to do
for um for direct consumer businesses i
sit on the board of a company called
brewmate which makes like um like you
know drinkware uh think like you know um
uh like hydration kits or or can coolers
for slim cans
they had one employee and they were
doing 30 million dollars a year like
only the founder dylan was at the
company and he was doing 30 million
dollars a year now he had some
outsourced agencies that he was working
with to help him run to help him run
facebook ads and to help him do customer
service stuff but like he had one guy
and one guy in the payroll so you could
easily flex up and down with those
agencies depending on how the business
was going uh so i think uh hiring uh
over hiring is a real problem uh the
other thing i think is like another way
to spend money poorly is like a
beautiful office i remember walking into
some direct consumer founders businesses
when i was running native and i was like
wow this brand is super successful look
at how nice this office is they have a
big they have a logo on their uh you
know on the wall right when you walk in
after we sold our business the first
time png came to our office because you
know we've been doing it off-site so as
not to tell everyone you know if if 13
people from procter gamble walk into our
office with eight people people are
going to be like hey what's going on
here so we were kept meeting off-site
and finally when they walked in
they you know there was a sticker on the
door that said native like it was it was
a sheet of paper i had written out
native by uh with a sharpie marker and
taped it on the door and that was our
office it was like you know done with
one penny uh and they were like is this
seriously your office says like yeah of
course this is their office and they're
like this is the cheapest office i could
possibly have imagined and i was like
hey we care about dollars and so you
know i used to be afraid of being frugal
and i'd be like wow i'm so embarrassed
now i'm like it's a real badge of honor
we're running a fiscally cons like you
know we're fiscally conservative when it
comes to this business and we care about
dollars and they're my dollars i don't
want to spend them well uh so i think
that's the second thing and i think the
third thing is really poor marketing a
lot of founder like if i could if i ask
a founder hey what is your cac last
month and you don't know that is a
terrible sign if you're doing uh under
40 million dollars a year in revenue and
you don't know where your cat was last
month that's crazy if you don't know
what your attack was yesterday that's
okay but like you should know what a pro
you probably should know and like you
know you you know if i ask you at 10 a.m
and you don't know that's okay if i ask
you at 2 p.m and you still don't know
where your cafe's yesterday that's a
real problem you're just not involved in
the numbers enough like this is how you
grow these businesses it's paid ads or
some some sort of advertising spend uh
versus a return on that investment and
if you're not familiar with those
numbers you're you know being grossly
negligent with your business
and you you used to do a bunch of like
kind of like hands-on unscalable stuff
like this so i think you know
i don't know to this day but like you i
showed you what we do as far as this
morning we were talking and i showed you
what we do as far as like
every day in excel we hand write here's
something yeah here's the yeah here's
the new customers we got here's the
blended roast here's the cac here's how
much from email and we write that every
single day into this like spreadsheet
and i'm sure there's like more automated
ways to do it but it's not perfect and
like the practice of doing it by hand
makes you think about each of these
numbers because you're like why is this
number always 52 and like i need to get
this number to not be 52. i'm tired of
writing effing 52 on this spreadsheet
like i just if this is if this number
was 42 we would be making so much more
money okay that becomes my daily focus
um what are some and i've seen you tweet
out about like people going and like
like they go to target they like watch
the aisles themselves to see how people
are buying their brand or what they're
not you know what what they're doing
when they choose the brand what are some
of those unscalable things you've done
yourself or what are your favorite kind
of like give me some scrappy stories of
like
stuff that that like you did as an
operator or your favorite operators have
done
sure um you know i i used to email every
single customer native and i was like
hey what um you know you bought our
deodorant uh do you like it or do you
not like it if you like it leave a
review and if you don't like it email me
back and tell me why you don't like this
and you know we were doing three hundred
thousand two hundred fifty thousand
dollars in revenue before we hired our
first customer service uh rep like i was
looking at every single one of those
emails being like what's working here
and what is it
and that's how we got our product better
we'd listen to consumer feedback and you
know we sent out you know we were doing
500 600 orders a day probably more than
that so we're getting a lot of customer
service responses to that type of
inquiry but literally every single
customer who ever purchased from us i
would wait like you know five days until
it was too late for you to return the
product because if you emailed us and
you're like i hate this thing
can i return it i want to be like no
you're past the return deadline you
can't do that any longer so i literally
had it scheduled for like you know at
native you could return a product for 30
days i had it scheduled to go on day 40
because i was like you know it's gonna
take five days in shipping and so day 40
we would email you and be like tell us
what you like and what you don't like
and uh you know we're gonna go and try
and fix these things we once had we
invited a bunch of consumers to a
location and then started grilling them
with questions hey you know they were
consumers that have purchased from us a
bunch they lived in san francisco and
were like why do you like native
deodorant why do you think it works
better than other deodorants in the
market because uh and you know people
would be like it has probiotics that's
why it works better than uh than other
deodorants and i was like what makes you
like it does have probiotics but you
have no idea whether that's effective or
not but i was like no matter what we do
with our formula we have to keep some
level of probiotic in there because
people think probiotic means efficacy
whether it does or not and so those are
the types of things that were really
interesting and fun and um you know
non-scalable you know i also you were
talking about um solomon was talking
about my business and how i packed boxes
i did pack boxes i packed boxes until
we're probably doing about 80 000 in
revenue a month like you know monday
wednesday and friday i would go home
after working put on star trek and start
packing boxes
and you know i was like okay i do i knew
how much a box weighed i knew how much
filler paper to put in there i knew how
much a box weighed when like you know
with deodorant without deodorant um i
knew how to optimize this price i i knew
when we were creating custom boxes i was
like i want our box to weigh 1 ounce and
not 1.3 ounces because at 1.3 ounces it
tips us over this level and at one ounce
it doesn't i'd go to our contract
manufacturer all the time be like hey
we're seeing these types of [__] ups
what's going on here and so i was like
intimately familiar with the formula i
knew the steps to how to pour the
formula what what temperature we ported
out at and like native was being hand
poor we were making 20 000 units of
native a deodorant a day and we were
hand pouring each single bar so there
was there were about 100 people working
in austin texas hand pouring deodorants
and
you know the best person could hand poor
about a thousand deodorants a day and a
new person could and pour about 75
deodorants a day and we had to train
these people to go from 75 to a couple
hundred or 500 and that was really
interesting as well and so there was a
and i mean that's not scalable certainly
hand-pouring deodorants isn't scalable
but we went from 500 units of deodorant
a week to 21 000 a day still hand
pouring so it was more scalable than i
thought it was going to be
and how much of that is you being a
maniac versus like good strategy right
so like if somebody in my company was
doing that i'd be like why are you doing
this you need to hire somebody so you
can do something higher leverage but
clearly it kind of worked for you to be
like a maniac and doing all the things
yourself so like you know what's the
line what's the right way to think about
that
uh yeah that's a great question i think
if you're completely divorced from
customer feedback you're setting
yourself up for disaster unless you've
created a you know a flywheel that you
know exactly how it works like you know
when native was doing hundred million
dollars of sales a year i probably
wasn't in customer service any longer
but when it was doing 50 million in
sales a year i was in cu you know i was
probably the number one if not the
number two customer service agent and so
like you know you need that feedback to
understand what's working and what's not
where are their problems in my business
and where they're not and so
uh look i don't know what the right line
is but divorcing yourself from customer
feedback at under 25 million dollars a
year is bananas to me you're not gonna
know what people love about your product
and what they don't love and you're not
gonna know like you know we'd have
operational issues that i wasn't aware
of we'd be like shipping is taking an
extra three days when it go when it's
going to california what's going on here
like is there a problem in california is
there a problem with our shipping
company sometimes we'd run out of things
and no one would know until a customer
emailed us being like hey i'm waiting
four days and we're like we're out of
this we're out of coconut and vanilla i
don't believe and then we check our
inventory and we're like how did we run
out like we did such a not only did we
do a poor job at uh inventory
forecasting we weren't even aware of
that we ran out when we ran out and so
uh those were a couple of the ridiculous
things that would happen uh but like you
know because you're intimately involved
you're able to like you know uh
understand the business at a deeper
level and i think like really being
engaged at you know what does my
shipping look like you know how can i
make shipping faster so i can reduce
costs is the weight of the box or the
weight of the filler or the size
different there was a company that i
knew that i i was friends with the ceo
in san francisco his bo he was shipping
through amazon and his box uh that he
was shipping in was about a half inch
too large and it went from being extra
like it went from being like a large box
to a custom large box and so his
shipping rate went up like 70 a box
because of this half inch he had and
like you know when people discovered it
or when he discovered it he's like i
can't believe we've been shipping like
this for so long you know if you're
intimately involved you're probably
gonna catch those things a little bit
earlier
right
and so you let's zoom out so you um
you've seen d2c change you
uh
you also have seen you know you also
invest in the stock market and so you've
seen
shopify amazon facebook give me on each
of those three stocks give me your lay
of the land on like
what you think has happened and where
you think that those are going are they
trending are they rightly priced are
they
underpriced are they overpriced you know
give me give me let's do shopify first
and then uh we'll do facebook and then
amazon sure okay and for context i've
lost millions of dollars in shopify
stock in the last six months uh and you
know i wrote this twitter thread about
it as well and i was like uh shopify
keeps uh there are their mottos to arm
the rebels and i said they keep giving
us muskets in a war that's being fought
with like nuclear weapons
and you when you put out tweets like
this and you you basically say hey
here's what i think you should do with
your strategy or if i was ceo here's
what i'd be doing or like as somebody
who's lost millions of dollars on your
stock here's some things that i think
could help
do you ever hear back is it crickets do
you get other interesting inbound what
happens after you put that out there
because i've done that a few times and
i've gotten very interesting
uh situations occur from my my tweets
like that what's happened for you
definitely interesting situations uh
toby who's the ceo of shopify respond
and he's like these are great points so
did harvey who's the president and
definitely had some more interesting
calls and i'm not sure if that that
twitter thread which was a couple months
ago now
you know inform them and help them
create this look-alike audience system
that they're creating at shopify but
that's wonderful i don't want any credit
just go do it so that we can go get
cheaper
you know cost customers so that we can
acquire customers at a cheaper rate and
build better businesses like you know go
build out these products and make the
platform fantastic you know a bunch of
people pay clavio more than they pay
shopify a bunch of people pay recharge
more than they pay shopify look these
are shopify apps that it provides you
with a small segment of like or a small
thing compared to what shopify uh
enables you to do
you know provide some of these services
at cheaper costs or build in some of
these services to make the platform
better like you know triple wheel is
doing a fantastic job at analytics why
doesn't shopify build their own
subscription platform instead of
outsourcing it to recharge which
everybody hates and which charges a
fortune like what's going on there it's
been you've been publicly traded for
years this this is arming us uh this is
arming the rebels and so let's let's
shift away from d2c let's do other types
of investing because you do real estate
um you've tried to buy pieces of sports
teams you've tried a bunch of different
things so let's just start with the big
picture so give me a pie chart
percentage-wise of
what do you do with your money so you
you yeah you came to a bunch of money
you
what's in cash what's in real estate
what's in stock what are you doing
percentage-wise roughly for those
great question um great question and i
think the answer is i should know the
answer i i know my cat from yes
yeah
this is me not knowing my cat which is
embarrassing um that like uh probably
around 10 million in private equity
um
probably around 40 million or 50 million
in cash
uh which is a lot and not like cash cash
where i'm like literally holding in cash
but like really short-term bonds waiting
for bond prices to go up and so now i'm
starting to leg into positions where i
feel like interest rates are getting
more more exciting and so i'll put my
money there um so you know i've been
investing in really short-term bonds
that you know aren't really subject to
much
interest rate risk because they've got
six-month maturities
and not five-year you know uh bonds that
are more subject to interest rate risk
and you know since interest rates have
gone up over the last four months i've
started to deploy more capital in that
respect uh but a lot of cash
um probably
25 million in real estate 30 million in
real estate that i'm like you know that
i or you know my family owns and we're
operating ourselves and then probably
another 10 million in real estate as lp
somewhere uh here or there um
i don't know how much money that is uh
but then there's like you know i don't
know then there's like random and
probably another 10 million in um
startup investments
um
so
maybe more than 10 million for
investments
good question probably around 10 million
in the stock market uh maybe a little
bit less now that shopify and facebook
have gotten cremated uh
so maybe less than that now but i'm not
exactly sure what the amount is there
and why such a big cash position is that
to be conservative is that just i'm so
busy i haven't figured out how i'm going
to deploy all this
yeah or is it like intentional like no i
want to have let's say 50 40 50 cash and
kind of bonds it's more reactive than it
is proactive like i'd love to be more
invested and part of it was actually
like you know proactive in terms of
waiting for interest rates for uh to go
up again because you know if you
invested two years ago or three years
ago you've barely gotten any return on
your dollar so i was like we can sit on
cash and not be subject to so much
interest rate risk now i'm getting more
excited about that but a lot of it is um
you know
when you get to a certain scale of
wealth you hire professionals who are
like private wealth managers to help you
deploy your capital in a way that's
really intelligent a way that's unique
and um
you know supposedly gives you a
competitive edge because you have more
capital to deploy so you're able to hire
smarter people to deploy that and you
know earn a greater return that's the
shtick that they sell you i'm not sure
that stick is real at all like uh
private wealth managers have been
really disappointing like no one is
doing anything unique in this industry
you know if you ask two private wealth
managers what's the difference between
you and this other person they'll just
[__] on the other person and you'll be
like what are you gonna get me like what
are you gonna invest me in that this
person isn't like what's your
competitive advantage do you have access
to deals that this person doesn't have
access to uh they're like no we're both
managing the same amount of money we've
been around the same amount of time and
they're like you know have you heard of
elliott i'm like yeah i've heard of
elliot the wall street journal every
[__] day i'm pretty sure everyone
could get me in like you know their fund
is 20 billion dollars i'm sure anyone
could get me in there and they're like
yeah anyone could get you in there but
we know them really well and i'm like
okay i don't know what that means
um and so like i guess where i've been
disappointed and where i've been lost in
this world uh is
how do i deploy my capital in a really
effective way and you know every like
you know if i tweet something about this
i tweeted like hey if you've got 300 000
if you're earning 300 000 a year it's
really hard to know what to do with your
money you're not rich enough for the
private wealth manager and you're too um
rich for the bank of america person who
sits at the retail branch and you know i
got a bunch of um people who are like i
do this for 300 000 people who are about
300 000 a year i didn't vet any of them
but like they were aggressive and like
you know these private wealth managers
if you sell a business they just reach
out to you and they're like help us let
us manage their money and you're like
what are you going to put me in and
literally none of them say anything
unique none of them have their own
things they're just like we're gonna
invest you in this other guy's uh fund
and every private wealth manager can get
you in there for instance with public
equities they all tell you go invest
with parametric they do tax loss
harvesting so you'll get an extra 0.25
to 0.5
return over the s p 500 if you invest
with parametric as opposed to doing this
as opposed to just investing in a
vanguard etf but they all tell you to do
that why would like you know why use
goldman sachs instead of first republic
instead of a smaller boutique fund if
you're all just going to invest with
this dollars with parametric you're all
the same at that point it's like you
know it's like buying an airline ticket
from kayak or expedia but riding on
american airlines and getting the exact
same seat ultimately you're getting the
same product and so i haven't been smart
enough and spent enough time figuring
this stuff out
gotcha and then what about uh crypto you
don't do anything crypto and is there
like a strong opinion like oh it's all
you know fugazi or or or you just
haven't had time
uh very little with crypto i'm like an
investor in a couple fund of funds that
have made a fortune in crypto so these
funds have returned a a significant
amount and it wasn't in their sort of
like fun charter to go invest in crypto
but they did it anyway and they're like
look we're up you know ten thousand
percent so you can't complain you know
they're like look we turned your dollar
into ten thousand dollars you can't be a
you can't be an [__] lp what the [__]
you can't do this they're like here's
ten thousand dollars shut the [__] up so
you know they can do it um
generally i just don't understand the
value yet and um so i've been hesitant
to get in there i'm not opposed to it
you know everyone says invest five
percent of your net wealth in it i
wouldn't invest five percent of my net
wealth in it um you know it's hard
because uh the same parts of the world
are like boys you're not investing in
crypto what the [__] are you doing and
the warren buffets of the world are like
if you offered me all the crypto in the
world for twenty dollars i would not buy
it and so um i guess i've just been
sitting on the sidelines i don't know if
that's good or bad uh but if someone has
a strong opinion can convince me please
do so
okay i'm gonna resist the urge to do
that now because people have brand too
many times on it um all right so
okay so let's let's do a little bit like
uh
let's do a little touch on a real little
real estate then we'll do the personal
stuff so real estate yeah you've been
deploying but now it feels like the
landscape has changed i think you kind
of have an opinion on what's changed
give me your current take on like what
do you see and what are you doing
yeah so uh i left a native in uh
february 2020 and um right when covert
was gonna hit like i was like i'm gonna
go to europe and i'm gonna i'm gonna go
to france i'm gonna try and drink all
the wine they produced in 2019
in february 2020 in france and uh then
covet hit and instead i was stuck with
my parents like you know all day uh it
was a very different experience than i
suspected it was going to be um and so i
started buying real estate and so from
like january or from february 2020 to
probably the end of 2021 i bought about
uh or so units um generally single
family homes some duplexes some four
flexes uh two units in uh you know all
and aside from those 50 units two units
in like uh california where uh they're
like old apartment buildings that are
really small and we're renovating and
then i was an lp in a bunch of different
funds
um you know
everyone who bought in 2019 you look
like a [__] genius like people are
like wow you're such a savvy real estate
investor i was like i started buying
because i had nothing else to do you
know if they were going to return money
they're gonna return five percent
they're returning 12 14 now and that's
fantastic but i'm not sure i was very
savvy about it um i i haven't used
leverage which is really stupid of me
and you know uh it's really stupid today
because if i borrowed you know a year
ago i would have gotten two and a half
percent interest i could just invest in
that 10-year bond and made money i just
haven't used leverage in part because
i'm too lazy to try and get it and in
part because i'm like you know i've got
enough capital to deploy already
um
and the returns have been fantastic you
know i bought homes and i was
underwriting for six percent returns
that are 12 14 returns they're crazy i
bought a four plex for six hundred
thousand dollars i thought each unit
would rent out for like eight hundred
dollars they're each renting out for
about fourteen hundred dollars now so
it's i'm making a fortune uh people are
struggling with rents and so state
governments are often stepping in and
providing rents to landlords like you
know we get a call being like hey john
can't pay his rent we're going to cover
the rent for the next 18 months and you
know they'll cut you a check for 18
months of rent and late fees which is
bananas um and so it's been a fantastic
investment but yeah i am slowing down
now
and uh
do you think where do you think this
goes are you gonna you're slowing down
but you're slowing down because you sort
of are like okay i'm allocated how much
i want to be allocated or you're slowing
down because like wait this no longer
these prices no longer make sense
uh it's not even the prices don't make
any sense any longer because
this is the one asset class where i'm
like i have a really long term view you
know stocks i look i've been in shopify
never sold a share facebook i've been in
i've never sold a chair have had them
both for five years if not longer uh
microsoft i've been in for more than a
decade i remember buying it while i was
in in my admin law class in law school
and i've still held every one of those
shares so like you know generally like
i'm a pretty good long-term investor
real estate i think of myself as uh like
you know i will never sell any unit uh
in in real estate like my children will
inherit this
um or you know natural disasters will
take these things uh into the ocean i'm
okay with either of those but i will not
sell one under any circumstance so i'm
not really worried about prices uh you
know in in terms of cap rates long term
but i do think there'll be a small
market correction so i i guess i've
slowed down my purchasing i'm still uh
under contracted by two or three units
in the next couple months but i'm not
like before i was trying to buy you know
a unit a week or you know two units a
month and now i'm sort of like let me
buy a unit a month or less just to see
what happens to the market as interest
rates go up and i think these prices
will come down a little bit but i i like
you know
a lot of my cash is in real estate you
know 25 30 million dollars
uh i i'm not scared like you know if the
market crashes no nobody will be more
excited than me i will deploy all the
cash i'm sitting on for this i have no
problem if that 30 million dollars goes
down to five i will not get like this is
the one asset class where i will not get
scared i will double triple or quadruple
down as opposed to being like oh my god
i gotta sell what i've got
and that's just because you're like this
is a concrete assets there's limited
supply there's always going to be demand
it's such a daisy mentality you know
it's like my parents mentality like it
cash flows it's immune to facebook ad
prices it's immune to the stock market
it's like generally uh like it's real
diversification for my e-commerce and
startup investments like these things
they'll exist um they're generally
they're primarily in the south with the
exception of a few in california and a
few in colorado they're places where
people are moving to and not moving from
um and so i'm excited about them and uh
yeah so i would never i have no desire
to sell them get emails and calls all
the time no excitement whatsoever to
sell love holding this stuff and
generates a ton of cash and you know the
other way i think about it is um and
this is also pretty decent mentality is
like okay i've got all these expenses
per year and no job
i need something to make up for that
like these expenses like i don't want to
dip into capital i don't believe in like
you know like balance never goes down
that's right i'm terrified of the
balance going down and so i'm like i
need something to
afford my lifestyle and this real estate
helps me afford my lifestyle
how do you think about that
i'm i don't know
if i'm just too dumb or too lazy but
it's one of the two where i'm like
um
i basically picked two lanes to think
about
and i was like i don't really have the
like mind share
to be able to think about like if i go
into real estate today i'm the dumbest
guy in the room okay well it doesn't
take a genius to do real estate so
that's okay i think if i put my mind to
it i could do that but that's now my
mental cycles that are not going towards
my business or the stuff i'm more
interested in where i think i can have a
bigger edge where i think i can be more
like the top one percent rather than
like the 60 you know 60 percentile or
whatever sure and so that's the first
part is like do i want to try to learn
this game from scratch
if i'm going to do anything direct or
even if i'm going to invest in funds i
got to have some ability to vet these
funds to pick yeah but okay they're all
pretty safe you can get your five six
percent it seems like you know without
you it's not totally variable like that
um
the other thing is like in direct i'm
just like who's gonna have the time to
manage all this like i did one
transaction buying my house that i was
gonna buy i was gonna live in in san
francisco and just the process of the
dealing with the bank to get the loan
and then the closing the escrow and then
the inspections and
it was like um i couldn't do anything
else i was like paralyzed from like
actually doing stuff i liked because i
was constantly having to nurse this
project and i was like i can't imagine
buying 50 units in a year
um or you know 20 units in a year and
like the amount of just transactional
like logistics that i would have to go
through it's such a turn off from like
for what is the return basically the
same average as the stock market in the
long term okay like
i don't have to diversification is not
that important to me to like do both of
those things like the mental cycles plus
the physical energy it would take to do
the transactions and then manage them
and then like
you know my my tenant calls you know my
property manager calls me about the
tenant that's calling me about whatever
i don't actually even know what goes
into it but i know it's not nothing and
right now my tolerance is nothing for
like like headache
yeah and this isn't like you know
someone calls you on a monday being like
my ac is broken and it's in san antonio
texas
you can't be like okay i'm gonna get
back to you thursday like you know it's
110 degrees outside you need to get that
fixed in the next 12 hours so you're
right there is a lot of pain there when
i was purchasing manager i rent the
current place that i live in and i
called and was like hey there's like a
weird smell he's like okay so like where
does it come from i don't know it's a
smell
i can't see it he's like okay like what
kind of smells like i don't know it's
just like bad it's like smells really
bad and he's just like okay you gotta
give me something and i was like and
it's sunday and like you need to send
someone here because i can't have a
house with a bad smell like and i'm just
like i got kids you know that that's the
card and i'm like you got to send
somebody now to figure out this mystery
thing
and then the the guy comes over he's
like where's the crawl space i'm like i
don't know it's not my house i don't
know go ask this guy in arizona who owns
this house who's 90 years old go ask him
where the crawl space is of this
property because it's his problem to
like fix this for me and i'm just going
to be a baby about it and then i think
about what it's like to be on the other
side of that and i'm like is that worth
the like 500 like net that he's making
per month on my my rent it's like
probably not for me definitely not yeah
yeah you're absolutely right about that
and what was in the crawl space it was
like i don't know we never found it yet
the guy didn't get back to me and now
i'm pissed like
we have no idea
where it is
the guy like sealed up one hole so he's
like maybe this will help the smell go
away that was it i was like okay well we
still don't know what's causing the
smell you just bottled it up like
whatever's in the wall that's dead or
whatever is going on here yeah sure he's
like you know he's like he the guy came
over and on google translate he tapped
out he's like if the smell's still here
tomorrow i'll come undo the whole wall
thing i just did and i'll go find what's
in there i was like bro can't you just
do that now
can we not go into the wall now what do
we got to do with that on google
translate that's hilarious um yeah a
bunch of a bunch of the real estate i
bought is like at auction and so um when
you walk like they're very there's no
inspection there's no financing ability
like you know you bid on an auction you
you're right you know you wire the money
the next day and then you open the house
and you're like what did i just get into
and so um sometimes you'll walk in like
there was one house i i purchased and
the guy passed away not in the house but
like everything was still inside of his
house forks and knives spoons his cars
were in the garage get a safe in there
we had to empty of the entire house out
before we could rent it out and you know
you have no ide
like that was a mediocre situation
because like you know everything was
still in okay shape he used to live
there there was another house i got that
was in perfect shape like you couldn't
like you know you go into the house and
like try and look through the blinds to
find out what the condition is gonna be
inside this one you couldn't see at all
it's the only house i've been to where i
was like i couldn't see it all and i
opened up the lock but after i bought it
and it's in perfect condition there have
been houses that i bought i walk in and
i'm like [__] i just you know i'm gonna
have to spend forty thousand dollars
that i didn't underwrite for replacing
the roof or changing the tile or putting
in a new kitchen and so it is a lot of
like rolling the dice uh at least in the
way that i've purchased and sort of uh
using you know the law of large numbers
to be like this is going to make sense
at some point and sometimes it does and
sometimes you get screwed and you know
you just eat the ones that got screwed
like there's been two that i've
purchased
in two years ago that are still not
rented because i haven't done the work
to go and fix the houses to make them
habitable um and that's you know that's
a lot of capital being that was deployed
and nothing's happening with right now
that yeah you need to just like get some
youtuber who does like he's trying to
make content about like renovating home
be like hey you can use my home and like
you get you know x percent and you get
to use all the content this is your home
sir go ahead and make it go ahead and
flip this thing
definitely
you and your brother both do this which
is i think you treat business like a
like a like business is your fun like
your adventure i i feel the same way and
i asked him because out
he gave me money and he he was like i'm
gonna advise your company and i was like
cool but like
just so you know like why are you doing
this like i want you to do this but like
as your friend i'm like why are you
doing this it's a waste of your time
like this is never gonna make enough
money to move the needle like your
share of this is never gonna make enough
money to justify the time and energy and
like it's not going to move the needle
for you so like really this makes no
sense why are you doing this and he goes
he says he goes um
he goes like i am not happy
unless i am like um
entrapped in you know in a business and
he's like but he's like as long as i get
to create the i want to live in a prison
of my own making and like as long as i
get to choose i'm good but like i'm also
not like i can't be content and
fulfilled unless i'm
like unless i'm locked into like a
raging battle with like you know some
like business thing and i was like wow
that's crazy but it also makes sense to
me and you're the same way when you're
like how do i do real estate on hard
mode like you could just lp a bunch of
funds and you're like no i'm gonna go
buy stuff i'm not just gonna buy good
stuff i'm gonna buy stuff at auctions
and i'm gonna go have to take like a you
know two by four and break off a lock
and then like walk in and see what i got
and then like figure out how to turn
this into like 1400 a month of rent
and you're like yes
sign me up whereas i'm like that's like
that's what you do to get to your your
spot you got there and then went back to
the beginning and like i'm now gonna
call you i don't even know this analogy
but like i always heard my engineers
talk about servers that run on bare
metal i don't know enough about servers
to know what the [__] that means but it
was always like what's the most like
hardcore way this server can run it's
like optimized for performance and like
just just the term bare metal like just
told me everything i needed to know
about what the hell they were talking
about it's like this kind of waste of
time hard mode way of doing something
that does yield like the best return and
like satisfaction of like optimizing the
space yeah i was like squeezing the
juice out of the fruit and like to me
it's like moyes you're like you like to
operate on bare metal it's like you're
choosing to play this game on like
you're like how do i hand write my utm
parameters on my ads and then like how
do i you know stock my deodorant sticks
myself and answer every customer service
question and then how do i like buy real
estate at a foreclosed auction with no
financing and no diligence and then like
figure out how to make that work you're
bare metal
you know there is like um first about i
learned how to break into houses like i
learned how to pick locks because of
real estate like i can walk into a house
now and like open it up pretty much
because and like i carry tools with me
when i'm traveling to these houses to be
able to like open up homes so that i can
go inside which is a little bit crazy um
in fact i saw my parents my parents are
you know two or like an older uh indian
couple obviously that are like in firm
and walk you know my mom will be like my
knee hurts and she walks with a limp and
then when she's trying to break into a
house with me she'll turn into like yoda
where if she could do spins she's like
what if i climb up to the top of the
ceiling and like go
you know jimmy down the chimney i think
i can get us in there and i'm like i
thought you need her but now now you're
perfectly fine you can like climb this
wall and like you know go up the uh go
up the into the chimney and she's like
yeah i got it for this
uh but i think that really i think
there's a lot of um in my family there's
just a lot of interest in business and
so being an lp is a ton of fun and i'm
an lp in a bunch of these uh real estate
funds and i'm like looking at the
numbers and some are making good money
and some aren't
but like you know there's no um
sexiness to it it's uh it's a paper
money like you know bring me to sexy
problems like oh your toilet is broken
what the [__] are you doing here why is
your toilet break every day uh oh the
government is gonna write me a check for
18 months this is crazy the government
is going to pay me late fees the
government is gonna call me and be like
hey boys you got a house here this guy
can't pay his rent we're gonna pay you
18 months of future rent and the last
two months and late fee for the last two
months tell me why you're doing this how
did you get to this uh who thought this
was a good idea
uh you know does greg i think this is a
good idea because that's a lot of money
you're gonna give me and so um
you know business is great and making
money is great but it's a lot more fun
to be an active participant rather than
a sidelines participant like i don't
wanna i don't wanna read what's in the
wall street journal and be like okay
that's great i want to be like a part of
that system that's going on there's a
great like analogy where this guy
who's a partner at a big law firm his
name was joe flom he worked at skadden
arps uh this was back in like the 80s
and 90s where there were all these
mergers happening um
he's he was like 80 years old and he
slipped and fell in his bathroom and his
head was bleeding and uh he walked into
this board meeting because he was part
of this board that needed to fend off a
hostile acquirer and he had paper towels
on his head because he was bleeding he
was 80 years old and people were like
what the [__] is going on you're
bleeding profusely and your 80s like i
slipped and filmed like go to the
hospital and he's like no i want to be
here and they're like what's going on
he's like i don't care if i'm you know
acquiring a company or fighting off an
acquirer i just want to be in the game
and nothing is going to stop me and this
guy was 80 and bleeding and had paper
towels on his head but he wanted to be
in the game and i really respect that
like i want to be in the game
that's where there's uh a lot of fun in
life
you um you watch basketball right
yeah
do you which like athlete or in any
sport doesn't matter which athlete are
you like i admire their like the way
they do with their thing is how i do i
think or how i want to do my yeah tom
brady tom brady for two like i remember
he won a super bowl and there was a 60
minutes like uh interview with him at
27. he was this was not his like you
know seven super bowl this is like his
second and they're like so what do you
you know you're a super bowl champion uh
nfl mvp what do you think and he's like
is this all there is to life like that's
what he said at the end he's like is
this all there is and you know then he
retired after two weeks he's like i
gotta get back in the game i have two
weeks off this is boring i need to be
back in the game and he's just like an
ultimate competitor and i really admire
that about him but i'm sorry that was
the answer to the question
that's that's great uh i don't do you
have five five more minutes i want to do
a couple of personal stuff all right so
what were you gonna ask about the
athlete stuff though i didn't mean to
interrupt you no that's what i was
asking i just wanted to know
who you admire
i can't find this client info have you
heard of hubspot hubspot is a crm
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases hubspot grow better
you uh we had a little dock i said put
down some bullet points i say you don't
have to explain what they mean but yeah
give me some nuggets that we could go
off of on it you had a section personal
stuff and you go you have two that are
really interesting to me you go i don't
know how to spend money what does that
mean yeah
um you know i'm living in airbnbs that
are like five grand a month uh i don't
have a car i don't have a house uh i
live out of a suitcase
um and like you know when expensive
things are like nice i'm like can i
afford like i still do the math of being
like this seems too expensive for the
value i'm getting even though that like
you know at this point a thousand
dollars probably has no value to me not
like no value but like it's not going to
materially change my life i'm still so
cautious when i'm spending twenty
dollars i don't know what that i don't
know how to get this out of my system
do you know how to get out of your
system um i don't know how to get it out
of my system i have no problem spending
money um
so too much money but like i've seen
this and i think you know the one of the
main things is i see my dad
and my dad has done really well right
like for he's got the same immigrant
story that like everybody has which is
you come to the country he had i think
91 dollars
that was starting point right so that's
the before and then like you know he's
made good money in his lifetime uh
nothing like you know
crazy to write home about but like
especially from a 91 dollar starting
point like
my parents have enough money to do
whatever they want they really don't
need to penny pinch but like you know if
we go to starbucks and it's like you
know would you like the he's like can i
have the small they're like okay it's
called tall he's like no but what's a
smaller than tall because i feel like
the tall is gonna be overpriced he's
like you know this is three dollars like
i i can make this it's mostly water like
and he'll be talking to the people about
it right i'm just like oh my god like
not only is this embarrassing but like
it's embarrassing in the moment because
he'll just be like let me clarify you're
saying the thing that's mostly water is
three dollars and eighty cents like oh
hold on hold on stop a lot
what's going on here or like you know
you know he'll pack seven people into a
hotel room because like you know we can
make it work it's like yeah do we have
to
um like we're on vacation here why does
it have to be a struggle and like and so
you know i just saw he could never get
it out of his system like those
the scarcity mindset was just so like
ingrained in him because and that's like
i all right i get it like he had no
safety net he had 91
like every dollar counted and like
it wasn't about spending it was about
like saving to get to build a safety net
because you're in this new car you're in
a foreign country your parents can't
help you nobody can help you like and so
i get that but i saw that like oh wow
you know actually the money come
it wasn't logical like once the money
was there that didn't change the mindset
didn't change so it's like i had to
separate out there's a mindset around
money and then there's like the logical
like situation about the money and like
there's actually like they're unrelated
you would think once the logical
situation changed the mindset will
change and it's like no it doesn't so
it's like an active thing and so then i
just started to like one of the reasons
i asked you who you admire and you're
like i admire this guy who's got like a
bloody head going into the board meeting
because he wants to do business that bad
i would view that as a failure and you
view that as a success and like
because i have this belief which is you
become what you admire right like
fundamentally yeah if you admire
something you're going to strive to it
so
it makes a lot of sense to really pick
and choose what you admire like i'll
give you an example a lot of people
admire elon musk
and i think elon musk is obviously super
incredible in a couple of ways like he's
one of the greatest inventor and
businessman of our time and like you
know the greatest since steve jobs i
would say
but like you know i think he's like an
edison of our time great sure um but
he's also had i think like you know i
don't know four failed marriages and
like that's not something i want for
myself so like i got to be careful
to admire the like the all-encompassing
person because i don't want
the al the full result of that like
the you know and so you gotta gotta like
so i got really specific about what i
admired and once i admired certain
things and i started to live life like
those people it's like well this guy's
really really happy
and like wow he's like pretty generous
and he's not generous based off of
having this like huge amount of wealth
he's generous because like
he doesn't feel super scarce about money
he doesn't feel this lack of money
um and so he's like willing to give and
like he's willing to give freely and he
doesn't think twice about it and he
doesn't pat himself on the back about it
either like oh wow i really admire that
about him like i want to be more like
that and so to me the only thing that
got me to change my mindset was knowing
that it's not going to change based on
how much money is in the bank and b
like i have to change who i admire
if i'm gonna like change who i become
right because like i will naturally
start to follow those blueprints uh and
observe people doing those things and be
like oh downloaded that like i will um
i will make that ha i will make that
happen like i'll give you a little small
win for me on this front like uh
i was just on vacation i was in hawaii
last week and like uh my parent my dad
is like i said like a horrible tipper
and like so my whole life i basically
saw my mom being like tip and my dad
being like you don't have to and like
you don't have to or like i did and i'm
like he handed him like a one like one
one was his tip and like the absolute
minimum and i just saw the look in the
valet guy's face or whatever like it
wasn't even valet like he wouldn't do
valet it's like the face of the guy who
you you're mandatory he's standing there
you gotta give him something the bellhop
right and it's like so this time um we
get to the place the bellhop takes up
our bags you know to the hotel room or
whatever and um i felt all those same
urges of like my upbringing which was
like we can just take the bags ourselves
it's like yeah but like that's this
guy's job and like it's not about being
lazy it's like that's how this economy
works that's how this ecosystem works if
i don't like you gotta feed the whole
food chain otherwise somebody's not
gonna eat right so it's like yeah okay
i'm gonna let him do that then we got to
the room it's like we have no cash
because i don't carry any dollar bills
like i only have cards
and so i've been in this situation like
five times before and i'm not i'm not
proud of it but like i would just be
like dude sorry i don't i don't have
anything i don't have any cash we just
got here i didn't bring cash or i would
like you know let the guy leave it at
the door and then i'd be like you know
not there to like tip the guy
and uh at this time i was like i was
like hey man like i'm so sorry i don't
have any cash on me what's your name and
like i made sure i went and got him
later and it was like again whatever 10
bucks but those 10 bucks meant a lot to
my to me and like yeah okay that's a
step in the direction of the guy who's
not
like has this lack mindset or scarce
mindset about money and is looking to
like hold on tightly to everything or
like avoid paying things it's like no no
um like
you know make it happen i actually had
like a a pretty comical series of events
where on the even on this trip where i
like my kid is two and a half but it but
i don't know if you know kids fly free
under two
yeah and so i bought first class tickets
because i'm trying to be a baller shot
caller but then i do the laptop i lie
about her age to make sure she's under
two and like i knew in the moment i was
like this feels wrong but it was also
like the logic was like well it's like a
couple thousand bucks to buy this
two-year-old kid a seat like i'm like
i'm really gonna do that
and then everybody told me they don't
check so i'm like i'm gonna get away
with it
and i got penalized so bad for this
cheapness that like it was just karma
teaching me this wonderful lesson
because we get to the plane and they're
like
oh you guys can't sit like sorry you
can't board the plane like what do you
mean like not only can i not board the
plane i'm first class but i get to board
first and they were like
no actually you have like two lap
infants you got two little babies
there's only like x number of masks in
the top thing so like there's three
masks and there's four of you we can't
let you board this plane we're gonna
have to ask to see if somebody wants to
switch seats with you for you to get on
this plane
and i was like what and i was like
nobody's gonna want to switch seats with
the people with the baby
and like have us sit next to them like
it's not gonna so sure enough they go on
nobody wants to switch i'm like all
right we'll we'll take uh like we'll buy
another seat like it's too late sir
they're sit flight's full like all right
we'll we'll go to coach we'll move back
like
coach is full
and i was like all right what's the next
flight like it's tomorrow i'm like oh
[__] i knew this little cheap move on my
part of lying about the four months of
my kids age would come back to bite me
and it did and so then like we my wife
and we had this horrible flight over
where like one my wife was on the last
row of the plane with a baby in the
middle row between two people and like
cause some guy was like i'll give up my
middle seat in the back like to now i'm
sitting next to this dude and so instead
of having this awesome family experience
having this terrible one because i
cheaped out and so i just started to pay
attention to all the ways
that saving money was costing me money
and costing me like joy uh rather than
like how much it's saving me and like
what i what i keep
and so then who do you admire then is it
somebody who's made that mind like who
is that yeah like my trainer so like i
talk about him a lot it's probably like
eye roll at this point but like uh the
happiest person i know and not happy in
like a cheesy way like but in a damn
i've never seen this dude not in a good
mood and like i've seen him stuck in
traffic for three hours i've been late
super [__] late and inconsiderate and
like you know like
but he greets me like he's he's just
been having a party he's like dude where
you been because his life is a traveling
party and so i saw that and i was like
man
on every conventional metric that like i
was raised like you you came from
brownfield it's like he's uh i think
he's like 41 42 years old he's not
married that's that's a like household
disaster if you're like a brown person
it's like you know we're having
interventions you know if that happens
um
you know he does well for himself as a
personal trainer but he's not like the
most successful guy i know like i'm
surrounded by people with more quote
success than him
um in terms of financial success
um
you know so like you know just in terms
of like the kind of conventional metrics
the things i thought were most important
you know his scoreboard it wasn't like
wow this guy i admire him because he's
successful it's like he's successful
with the game of life because this
dude's never in a bad mood
and like
because of that everybody wants to be
around him he's the most loved guy i
know because of that he has these like
magical experiences like you go to a
coffee shop with this guy and like
you're gonna have like something if you
just hang out with him for three hours
like something awesome is gonna happen
because his mood he's gonna make a joke
and then that person's gonna say this
thing then they're gonna take us to the
back room and hook us up because they
just got liked our vibe and like i tell
the story like he goes to the dmv
and like he you know he goes to the dmv
and it's like dmv is like the classic
like worst place on earth to be
and like he went in being like nah dude
he looked up the dmv on yelp and had two
stars
and he's like i'm gonna have a five-star
experience because i'm gonna be a
five-star dmv participant uh you know
and just watch what happened so he like
walked in with a little pep in his step
he's smiling and he makes a joke to
somebody and he realized and somebody's
like oh you could i'll just help you out
over here and everybody else is
grumbling in line like why is this guy
getting to go up front she's like don't
mind them and then she flirts with them
and like she she hooks and he's supposed
to take the test and she's like you know
what like it's fine you've been driving
for a long time and she just gives him
the thing and he's like walks out he's
like damn if i could do it at the dmv i
could do it anywhere right like that's
awesome he's like he's like i wasn't
always this way he's like dude i was
depressed for a while my dad died and i
used to be bitter about him for xyz and
he's like
he's like you know i used to be the guy
like i didn't want to come out from the
covers because i just wasn't looking
forward to my day like you know you if
you looked at me you just see like a
blanket and two eyeballs because i just
didn't want to get out of bed
and he's not saying this as a
motivational talk because he does he's
not a motivational speaker it's just
like he's my personal trainer i just
happen to hear these stories so when i
heard this i was like okay this dude is
winning the reason i want this money
this family is all these things because
i want to feel good this dude just feels
good on auto like he feels good no
matter what situation you put him in so
that's like an invincibility right like
he is unconditionally feeling good so
that's the guy i started to admire and
then i started to pattern myself after
things that he was any time i noticed he
did something different than me or my
friends or the people around me i like
took special note of that and like would
lean into trying that out as a new
experience to see you know
is that part of what makes him him
that's really interesting uh and a great
story and um
you know for a long i feel like everyone
i've admired i've just been it's almost
like uh
sex where i'm just automatically
attracted to that person it's not even
conscious like i just get an erection
when uh you know i hear about tom brady
because i'm like wow that guy is awesome
and really good at what he does and he's
his ultimate competitor and wants to win
um and i never realized i never even
thought that you could choose who you
admire i just assumed it was like you
know your sexuality where you're like
are you attracted to this person it like
comes from here and not here
yeah actually maybe that is true i think
there's some truth to what you said
uh but like in the same way that like we
don't all go try to marry porn stars
like there's a certain point where
you're like yeah what really matters to
what what do i actually want and it's
like yeah well there's this initial
thing this physical attraction which is
important uh but they're like actually i
now know it feels really good if
somebody who's caring and thoughtful and
like whatever like i can trust
and the the things that are like
slightly below the surface that like
you're like oh i actually now that i
know about it now that i felt it i'm
like those are super important i just
you know it's just less primal than like
the physical attraction i guess
yeah yeah that's a great point um
i've not done a good job of admiring
people that i know really well i've only
know like you know i admire people that
i just hear about their competitiveness
and their instinct to win
and i'm gonna think about that and try
to do a better job of that
your brother's like this your brother's
another person i chose to like admire
because i was like
he's also your brother's also like in a
good mood pretty much all the time
[Laughter]
i i've i've never seen him like i've
never seen him either
like in low energy like i've never seen
him just kind of like on autopilot to
switch his off and also like even when
he's like like i've never seen him
defeated either
so
so you know those are
so so you know when i've seen him i'm
like he walks in like when your brother
walks in the room like he sub he
unconsciously goes
all right and it's like he's expecting
like the parade to start and i'm like
bro this is just a bakery but he's like
all right what are you doing what are
you eating oh is that good all right and
like it's not that he's not like mr
smooth socially but his like will to
have a good time
or like to have the experience like in
his fullest
actually like imposes its will on
everybody else everybody has to
participate at that point because
they're like uh yeah it's a croissant
you want to try it oh you know what you
should actually do this and it's like he
forces the good time out of the the
average because he just literally walks
and he's like all right what are we
doing or he'll be like let's win and i'm
like let's win what we're not even like
playing anything like okay i have to
like
rise to your level or i have to stop
being friends with you because
uh that's just the way you're
approaching things and like either
that's just i'm out
or i gotta figure out how to be in and
being in kind of means like being on and
not just being like ho-hum about that
life you know
yeah yeah i've chosen to stop being
friends with him as a result of that
no in reality i actually in my room as
well and uh i know we're you know we
were at uh we were in texas uh for like
mother's day it was my father's birthday
two weeks ago
and um someone had gone to con i think
my sister had gone to costco and bought
like you know some cases of water and
like watermelons and i got home and
she's like hey boys can you get the
stuff out of the car it's like heavy and
like you know uh i i don't want to do it
and i was like why do you have salomon
he's been at home all day and she's like
he never does anything like he will not
lift a finger for this kind of stuff and
i was like this is why this guy's always
in a good mood no one asked him anything
that like you know is uh not enjoyable
because they know he's already said no
to it so often
that it's not like you know it's not
something that's asked or expected of
any longer that's why he's always in a
good mood uh but it is a lot of fun to
hang out with him like
and you know i've hung out with him
often enough to see both sides of that
when he's like excited and like the
energy comes and you know certainly
lifts me up and times where he's like
more analytical and he's like let's look
into this and does this make sense or
more like you know um i remember one
time when tinyko was struggling i was in
san francisco and he's like we have a
new strategy the whole business where
instead of creating our own iphone games
we're going to license the intellectual
property of others what do you think of
this this is like a bet the company move
and you know i had no idea i was a
lawyer and 22 and didn't know anything
um
but i was like i could i could get the
real sense of like it's not just pure
optimism there is a sense of reality
there and that also like helped me
understand him a lot more too
yeah he said something about you that i
thought was a baller line that i've i've
reused many times which was uh i don't
even know if this is the real thing but
this is now the the legend of it which
was when you went to the deodorant
business somebody was like hey moy's
like
do you even know anything about the
deodorant business are like about
deodorant
and you're like
no i know nothing about deodorant but in
six months i'm gonna know everything
there is to know about deodorant and
like that's that's enough for me to go
like i can start this i don't need to
like think of myself as some expert i've
used that so many times is that yeah
yeah that's true yeah that was
definitely true i remember who it was
too actually it was the husband of one
of my close friends who's like you don't
know anything i was like i use it and
i'll be an expert in six months
give me six months
that's an amazing attitude to have about
anything it's like yeah of course i
don't know anything and like give me six
months i could be pretty like i could be
pretty much an expert at anything if you
give me six months of obsession and you
get true with everyone sorry go ahead
your brother had some that were like
this because i started writing down
these traits i was like there's a um
what i call is like you know sometimes
you have a speaker system you turn it up
to level 10 and you're like oh it's
pretty loud it's bumping and then you
like get in someone's car and it's
almost like they got they theirs goes to
14. you're like god i can't hear
anything i'm deaf out of two like out of
my right ear because like why is your
[__] so loud but you're like okay at
least i know what loud is now i have
experienced loud even if i don't ever
want my speaker to be this intense like
i now know the level of intensity that
exists because i just thought 10 was the
max before and like that's what your
brother did like we invested in a
company together and they were kind of
[__] up and i was like dude can you
i'm trying to help these guys can you
help me help them like he's like yeah
great let's like all right let's win and
he gets on the call he does this clap
and he's like
and they're you know they're kind of
defeated and he's like okay so well
let's raise all this money you're trying
to raise money let's raise the money
like let's look at the deck and they
like put out the deck and it was like
awful and he's like okay so this is bad
um
but let's fix it like okay so he he
rattled off he's like slide three and
he's like super detailed right it's not
just like general ra ra he's like sorry
three that chart it makes me think this
you need to flip the numbers to be like
visualize it this way like this example
here on google images and he did that
for like this super detailed thing right
away and i was like whoa
and then he was like all right um
they're like wow thank you so much this
feedback's been so helpful he's like
great um how long do you think it'll
take you to to do this like to make
these changes and they're like uh i
don't know i'm gonna work on today like
you know i know it's super important so
i'm gonna work on it he's like great
it's
noon now let's talk at five and then
he's like send me a standing calendar
invite for 5 p.m every day for the next
seven days until this deck is amazing
and he's like let's just keep doing this
right like you said it was super helpful
right so let's just keep doing this and
i was like dude i wouldn't have had the
balls to tell any company i invested
like
let's meet again in three hours it
wasn't like forced it like even now when
i'm saying it it's not coming out the
same way where it was like
great let's do this and like let's just
shorten the time span right like let's
just cut all the fluff okay so you'll
make these changes like a couple hours
let's meet again and i was like i've
never done two meetings with the same
person in one day so then i was like oh
[__] i just found out my knob wasn't
even at ten it was at seven and like
this is what 12 feels like and he we did
it every day for five days straight
until the deck was amazing we would meet
twice a day with these people by the end
of it they hated us but like the deck
was so much like the whole pitch was
like the whole business was different
basically by the end because like
usually when a pitch is bad it's like
actually the business is kind of bad and
um
and so once i saw that i was like whoa
the ollie brothers they function at like
a different
like they have a different level 12 that
like
uh i like to see and i'm sharing this on
the pod because there's people out there
who the all the people around them
they've never seen like what 12 looks
like and i think you guys do this and
that's like my favorite thing about you
guys that's awesome i'm glad that that
worked out and yeah like he has this
insane ability to
get the most out of people and like uh
without
them feeling like it's an ex like
without that without him forcing it upon
you like you would do this when i was
running native he'd be like how can you
make this deodorant better than dub and
secret and i'm like this guy's an 8
billion dollar r d budget i've got 80
bucks i can't do this and he's like here
are five things that you can do that
like you know and he'll just even though
the like three of those things will be
outrageous um he'll be like go find a
new ingredient that'll work and i'm like
what am i supposed to you know dig and
find a new element in the periodic table
of elements
but like two of those things will open
up my mind in a way to be like you know
what i'm not trying i'm not focusing on
the right problem here and i gotta stop
thinking about retention and customer
service and all this other stuff that
matters but will matter later on more
right now this is my problem and forget
everything else and um it's really
humbling to be around that like whenever
i'm around him i'm always more jazzed
about business and my business
um and like you know i think we've seen
enough where we understand what the
problems are right away like i'm in some
of these board meetings and i'm like why
are we talking about like you know i was
in a board meeting a couple weeks ago
all we did was talk about fundraising
and i'm like this is a waste of my time
and your time either you're going to get
this check or you're not going to get
this check from this one guy stop
begging him like move on why don't we
talk about the business and see hey
what's working and what's not make a
better business and the dollars will
follow stop wasting time here and that's
what like it's so much of this is
experience and i had no idea that it
would be experience and i think about
this all the time i remember when i was
at nate when i was at the png
my boss who ran deodorants quit and i
was like oh he's quitting i hope he does
better and i didn't realize all of the
things that would happen to me that um
you know now are super clear like he had
made all these promises about keeping
native independent and amazing and you
know not not like forcing his will upon
the company and he had protected me from
png the next guy never made any of those
promises and so he didn't really feel
like he had to do any of those things
and i completely respect that but i
didn't even understand what was going to
happen when the guy told me he was
quitting and now i'm like okay when you
know head count changes this is what's
going to happen a new sheriff is going
to come in into town he's going to bring
in his own minions to work in the places
that he likes and either fall into line
or fall out like you know
leave the group and uh i didn't
understand that so much of this is
experience and once you go through those
go through these things it's super
helpful and you know he's had thought
he's had so much more experience than i
have and he's he's a little bit older
than me and so he's had it earlier than
i have and so he's been this great
sounding board for this kind of stuff
you uh you tweeted something out that
was great you're like here's my um
my project status like uh here's like my
my excel sheet i use for all my real
estate deals it was just like status of
it it's like you know um i remember what
it was exactly but it was like sent um
reply received waiting for
paperwork
um follow-up needed and then there was
one that was just like
i'm unsure i don't know what the hell's
going on
i don't know what's going on i don't
know where it's at like i don't know why
it's not moving and i was like that's
the status that i've needed in every
project i've ever done because my i
always have you know a tracker for
anything i'm doing i'm like all right
it's either like
i sent it i'm waiting for reply i got
the reply now i need to like reply to
them i need to analyze it i need to sign
i need to wire the money i need to do
whatever but like so often after like
24 hours every whatever status it was in
it's now slipping towards the black hole
of i don't know what's holding it back
from just finishing now yeah and i think
that's what you guys do really well
which is actually any initiative in any
project it's like
all right we're trying to you know like
get more profitable it's like well we
have this big plan and we're doing it
and then like surely slowly but surely
like a month and it's like
what happened to that whole
profitability thing are we doing it or
we not like and it's like yeah
everything has slipped into i'm unsure
what the [__] going on and i need this
like piercing clarity back and so hey i
think that was an amazing little tidbit
in there
i need that status because most things
are actually in that that bucket yeah
and i need to get them the hell out of
that bucket but i had to name it that to
like acknowledge what the heck was going
on yeah the second is
uh another example of the relentlessness
thing
uh level 12 level 14 on the volume scale
like i showed your brother this deal
that i was i wanted to invest in and he
was like oh this is like looks great
let's like let's do it and i was like
okay cool and he's like then every day
he would text me like what's going on
with that deal and i was like oh yeah
like uh no change like i emailed the guy
he said he's just he said he's
finalizing stuff he'll get back to me by
friday it's like tuesday so wednesday's
like yo what's up with the deal and i'm
like i think it's still the friday thing
i haven't emailed him again you think i
should he's like
yeah let's email him again and tell him
we love this and we want to be involved
and i was like oh is that like a thing
people do like that's just let's kind of
fluff him up he's like yeah let's just
keep it hot and i was like okay cool
then
wednesday thursday he's like i just feel
like we need to do something he's like
eventually got to the point where he's
like uh what's the guy's bank let's just
wire him a million dollars
and i was like we haven't signed
anything he's like well once we buy him
the money he's not gonna wire wire it
back so like we're gonna secure our
allocation in this deal just like let's
just send him a million dollars
and then he'll kind of be forced to like
finalize things with us rather than keep
us in this like limbo stage and maybe in
the end you'll say hey i can't do the
full amount you can only do a quarter of
the amount because i got all this other
investor interest because we know that's
what's going on here and again i was
like whoa didn't know that's an option
of like you can just wire the guy the
money i guess that kind of makes sense
and like
these are very very valuable uh little
tidbits of like yeah to add like another
example somebody gave us they were like
i was like what's your open rate on your
push notifications for your app i was
like oh it's like 30 i think it's pretty
good it was like 20 i think that's
really good industry average like eight
we're at 20. i was patting myself at the
back i was feeling happy
and he's like what do you think the
theoretical max is i was like what he's
like what do you think like theory okay
he's like it's not literally a hundred
you're not gonna get 100 people because
some people have uninstalled your app
and they have notifications off like
what do you think is like
and i was like i don't know what you
mean he's like i think i could get 50 of
people to open a push notification let
me just like see so he sent a push for
his app
and his app was like it was like a
social app like you post photos and he
just sent a post notification that said
um your uber is arriving outside um like
please like open this to to meet it at
the door like whatever he like sent the
thing that was like your uber is
arriving with your package swipe to like
open it up he saw like 55 percent of
people open that thing he's like okay
that's like
the juiciest i have to know what's in
this push notification he's like that's
now the max he's like anything
now we know so actually our twenty
percent is not on a hundred it's on like
fifty five percent and so everything we
do is from here and i remember thinking
wow some people in silicon valley are
like maniacs like they will push the
boundaries in ways that i just really
haven't thought of and every time i saw
someone break like an invisible wall
that i had just had up i'm like oh [__]
the game is so much more interesting
than i realized and like these people
play without these walls oh this is
awesome like what else can i do it's so
refreshing to see that kind of stuff
when you're like i don't know why i
thought this wall existed and now that
it doesn't it makes so much sense that
it doesn't exist like just break through
some it required some genius to break
through it and now that he's done it it
seems so obvious uh whenever someone i
look at like deals like one of our
investments are like uh you know raising
a new round we're always like we want to
either uh buy the business i want to buy
the whole business
run the business or sell my shares all
of my shares i want some action so i
can't look these are the three options
i'll buy the whole thing i'll run the
business you quit or get take all my
shares and get out of here but i don't
want nothing i can't do nothing here and
uh it's a lot of fun to like it's a lot
of fun to be involved and have that
action um
uh but you know it makes it so that you
admire a certain group of people
certainly
yeah exactly
and by the way this is a good example i
admire that uber push notification some
people like how unethical and weird and
like um you know why would you do that
and like you know if i told that and i
have done this many times like i've told
my designer hey let's try this and he
looks at me like i'm bernie madoff
saying let's take all their money and
run away like you know they think i'm
evil when i'm actually just running an
experi to me this is like an awesome
experiment and it's because i admire
people who did some of these different
growth hacky things that are like just
unusual thought experiments that i'm
like oh you the way you think is how i
want to think uh but not everybody
not everybody wants that or even thinks
it's good like they think it's bad which
is like but knowing that is also where
you figure out your lane you're like oh
that's my lane these things i think are
easy and fun and good other people think
are hard
boring or like are like evil and i'm
like oh okay cool i now know what
differentiates me from anybody else
there was this one great story that um
when i was a native we had bought we had
these uh uh end caps for target like
basically like shelving that was going
to sit at the end of an aisle and they
come in filled with all the deodorant
like you know we ship them and all they
have to do is take the box off and it's
filled and uh so we sent them to target
and uh nobody could find them like you
know there were a bunch of targets that
were like we don't have this and so
we're like okay what should we do and so
some png person was like okay what we
have to do is we need to call up the png
target team in minneapolis they're gonna
call up target target's gonna call the
distribution facility and then we're
gonna go all the way back around and
we'll find out where they are because
we've already shipped them and so um
someone on our team was like this
doesn't make any sense this is 15 phone
calls this is what you guys ordinarily
do and they're like this is the only way
to do it so we googled target
distribution facility in like new
england found their phone number
randomly cold called them and were like
hey we work in native uh i think you've
got a bunch of these end caps a bunch of
stores don't have it we shipped them to
you do you know where they are and
they're like give us 20 minutes to look
in the facility they called us back and
they're like yeah we got um we're going
to ship them out in the next truck and
that's how we solve the problem and like
you know to the p and jeers that had
never occurred to directly call the
facility and to google for that number
they're like we have to make 15 phone
calls and play secretary on the way back
and like you know their their mind was
blown and for us were like this is the
most obvious thing to do call the person
where the problem lies and um
it's it's it's crazy to see where those
walls are and it's so amazing to break
through them and be like this is the way
things should be done moving forward
can i give you one of those as well when
i was when we were yeah it's like twitch
twitches and amazon companies had like
the twitch bureaucracy plus the amazon
bureaucracy like there's layers you know
and it wasn't all bad but there was
certain things you'd run into it's like
this pocket it's like oh no i'm stuck in
molasses what is that where did i step
that like got me stuck and one of them
was for a period of time i believe there
was something with the performance
marketing where it's like so how much
are we spending on like you know getting
like installs and they're like uh you
know this amount like cool like what's
the cost like well we don't really have
the tracking like we don't tracking
that's like you know the basic they're
like well we don't want to install the
facebook pixel
because amazon doesn't really
necessarily want like we have to get
approval before facebook because when
facebook pixels in your app they have
your data they're kind of a competitor
to twitch and amazon so like you know
there's some sensitivity you have to get
that done like so we just spent we don't
know any we don't know the we don't have
the pixel installed like you can i don't
even know you can run an ad without the
pixel and then you're like yeah yeah and
i was like how long has it been like
it's been on legal's desk for like a
year and i was like oh my god and so i
was like oh wow so it's like we can and
so my job was at that time i was like oh
dude we're getting our ass kicked in
brazil and like nobody in the company is
even paying attention like we need to we
need to like win in brazil and like what
happened we used to be number one and
we're slipping because
like mobile gaming took off and we don't
do mobile gaming so i was like we need
to win
and um and so
we built a scraper first to like see how
fast the competitors were growing
because nobody in the company would do
anything unless you had a case for how
like much how big the market was so i
was like well look at the competitors
like yeah but like we don't know and i'm
like all right well we'll build a
scraper which is like startups do this
all the time but in a big company it
wasn't like super super kosher to do
that i was like okay whatever we'll do
until they tell us to stop
the second thing was
i was like oh we don't have this pixel
until we can't like run these ads so i
was talking i just went on a phone call
with this guy who was the number one
streamer in brazil that we had just like
paid a bunch of money to like come onto
our platform and i was like how would
you get a bunch of people to download
our app uh if i can't do facebook i
can't do marketing like paid ads
and he was like um he's like oh easy
boss and he's saying this the translator
is like he's saying uh it's easy bossy
you know here's what you need to do he's
like give me 10 iphones i was like what
he's like buy me 10 iphones i was like
what for i you know like i don't know
how to do that he's like i'm gonna give
away iphones iphone's like gold bars in
brazil if i just say i'm giving away
iphones on my twitch room everybody
download twitch
and you know sure enough i get i just
like kind of like bootleg away to get
the guy gift card so he could buy
iphones and um he buys 10 iphones he
does a stream where he's like i'm giving
my iphone he's like i'm not giving away
the first one until we have a like we
have 10 000 people watching my stream go
share this text your cousin text your
mom tell them to get on this i'm not
giving it away until then and then uh
and he drum up he had he bro he like he
was the number one streamer on twitch
that day he brought in himself like
hundreds of thousands of downloads like
the biggest download spike that we had
had
just by giving away like you know we
ended up giving away like five iphones
as like so for five grand basically we
did like more installs in a proven way
because they were all coming directly
off his link to his channel
and i was like and people
and that's when i knew like twitch might
not be the place because like i told
this story and i'm like i feel like i
slayed the dragon and i'm dragging this
carcass into the boardroom like in the
ninth floor
the mega boardroom are all the exact
same i feel like i'm dragging this
carcass in being like you know are you
not entertained you know and uh people
were like oh like you know that's
interesting uh and they just sort of
moved on and i was like wait
we just discovered this like incredible
growth hack to like get a bunch of
downloads if we did this thing out of
the ordinary like you know can we get a
little love here and when i got no love
i was like okay
um
this is not the place for me because if
this was my company and somebody did
this i'd be like look i don't know if
this was good strategy long term or a
bad one it's really irrelevant the fact
that you did this we need to tell every
team in the company that like something
like this is possible in your department
like don't get stuck in the molasses
like find something and try something
that works and like these guys have
tried nine things that failed tell them
tell them about all nine and then tell
them the one that worked and like i
would have gone on a road show for that
and that's how i knew like okay what
type of company do i need to be at is
one that like celebrates that type of
thing
that's a pretty amazing story and like
really amazing that this guy who's in
brazil is like i know how to get
downloads from this street like give
away iphones and get people to download
it that's brilliant of him and brilliant
that you found it and like harnessed it
and we're like [__] all this red tape
i'm gonna figure it out that's awesome
what an incredible story that's right
finally i'm getting finally getting the
love i needed yeah i've been waiting two
years to just get the
daddy i'm proud of you uh son i'm proud
of you moment but i i got it now all
right man sorry i took you so far over
the time thank you for coming on yeah
appreciate it thanks so much for having
me
yeah where should people find you your
twitter is probably the best spot right
yeah twitter on that moysali
lee all right perfect thanks man
perfect thanks
[Music]
you